Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I have done this with a loving heart for my father, Amun. I call to attention the people who shall live in the future, who shall consider this monument that I made for my father. It was when I was sitting in the palace that I remembered my maker. My heart directed me to make for him two obelisks of electrum, their pinnacles touching the heavens. Now my mind turned this way and that, anticipating the words of the people who
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我怀着对父亲阿蒙的挚爱之情做了这件事。我请未来活着的人们注意，他们将审视我为父亲制作的这座纪念碑。正当我坐在宫殿里时，我想起了我的造物主。我的心指点我为他建造两座琥珀金方尖碑，它们的尖顶触及苍穹。现在我的思绪百转千回，预想着人们的话语，他们
shall see my monument in future years and will speak of what I have done. He shall not declare what I have said to be an exaggeration. Rather, he will say how like her it is, loyal to her father, for I am his daughter in very truth, who glorifies him and who knows what he has ordained. So that's an inscription on the temple of Amun-Ra at Ipset-Sut in Thebes. The inscription, as you know, Tom, made by arguably Egypt's greatest female pharaoh, Hatshepsut. Well, arguably, I think definitely. Well, that's a big claim. Well, so we've done Cleopatra, haven't we? We have.
将在未来几年看到我的纪念碑，并谈论我所做的一切。他不会宣称我所说的是夸大其词。相反，他会说这多么像她，对她的父亲忠心耿耿，因为我确实是他的女儿，赞美他并且深知他的旨意。这就是底比斯伊普塞特-苏特阿蒙-拉神庙上的一段铭文。如你所知，汤姆，这段铭文由可以说是埃及最伟大的女法老哈特谢普苏特所刻。嗯，可以说，我认为绝对是。嗯，这是一个很大的说法。那么，我们已经讲过克娄巴特拉了，不是吗？是的。
But Cleopatra ends up a failure. I mean, she dies, commits suicide, her kingdom is conquered. Hatshepsut is a queen who reigns a millennium and a half before the time of Cleopatra, the beginning of the golden age of the new kingdom. And, you know, she's not just the greatest female pharaoh. She is one of the greatest pharaohs full stop. And she's not as well known as Cleopatra is that with Cleopatra, you have all kinds of brilliant details about, you know, what she was doing, what she looked like, what she was getting up to, all that kind of stuff, who she was sleeping with. With Hatshepsut, we don't have that kind of detail. We don't have the equivalent of a Plutarch or a, you know, a biographer or historians like that giving us the details.
但克娄巴特拉最终以失败告终。我的意思是，她死了，自杀身亡，她的王国被征服了。哈特谢普苏特是一位女王，她的统治比克娄巴特拉时代早了一个半世纪，也就是新王国黄金时代的开端。而且，你知道，她不仅仅是最伟大的女法老。她绝对是有史以来最伟大的法老之一。而且她不如克娄巴特拉那么广为人知，因为对于克娄巴特拉，你有各种各样精彩的细节，你知道，关于她在做什么，她长什么样，她在忙些什么，诸如此类的事情，她和谁睡过觉。对于哈特谢普苏特，我们没有那种细节。我们没有普鲁塔克那种水平的传记作家，也没有能为我们提供细节的类似历史学家。
Cleopatra is all the stuff about her is written by her enemies. So it's all very lurid and therefore very sexy, very colourful. With Hatshepsut, there is pretty much nothing. There's inscriptions, Tom. But I mean, that's all we're talking about, isn't it? Well, by the standards of pharaonic history, there's actually quite a lot. But by the standards of Greek or Roman history, there isn't. And by the standards of 20th century roman history there isn't and by the standards of 20th century history there really is you know we know about the most obscure of james callahan's cabinet ministers in the late 1970s yes then we do about this titanic woman but but i think that that what
关于克娄巴特拉的所有事情都是她的敌人写的。所以这一切都非常耸人听闻，因此非常香艳，非常丰富多彩。而对于哈特谢普苏特，几乎什么都没有。只有铭文，汤姆。但我的意思是，这就是我们所谈论的一切，不是吗？嗯，按照法老历史的标准，其实有很多。但按照希腊或罗马历史的标准，就没有了。按照20世纪罗马历史的标准，其实也没有，按照20世纪历史的标准，真的有，你知道的，我们对1970年代后期詹姆斯·卡拉汉内阁中最默默无闻的部长了解得一清二楚，是的，比我们对这位传奇女性的了解还要多。但我觉得，
you can do is to put her into the context of what is actually a very dramatic and thrilling story okay which is the recovery of egypt from a period of incredible humiliation and prostration so hatchet so it is born around 1500 bc um so you know if you go back further to kind of 3000 bc uh egypt emerges as a unitary state along the banks of the nile from the beginning you have these dynasties of kings the idea that the monarchy lies at the heart of this kingdom that the monarch is the kind of interface between the dimension of the gods and the dimension of of the earthly realm this first manifests itself through what is called the old kingdom the old kingdom these are building the pyramids all that kind of stuff then it kind of
你能做的是把她置于一个实际上非常戏剧性和惊心动魄的故事背景中，好吧，那就是埃及从一段难以置信的羞辱和屈服时期中复苏过来。所以哈特谢普苏特大约生于公元前1500年，嗯，所以你知道，如果你追溯到更早的约公元前3000年，嗯，埃及作为尼罗河流域的一个统一国家出现，从一开始你就有这些国王王朝，君主制处于这个王国核心的概念，即君主是神灵维度与尘世维度之间的某种接口，这最初是通过所谓的古王国时期表现出来的，古王国时期，这些人建造金字塔诸如此类的事情，然后它某种程度上
collapses into a state of of anarchy lots of different kings this is seen by the egyptians as a terrible thing then they recover and establish what is called the middle kingdom the middle kingdom again then collapses um around 1630 bc and the humiliation is that the northern reaches of egypt which include the pyramids, which include the ancient capital of Memphis, get conquered by foreigners. And these are foreigners who come from Palestine, Canaan, whatever you want to call it. And this is an unconscionable humiliation because the Egyptians are fabulously xenophobic, fabulously conscious of themselves as being superior to all the kind of the people who surround them and so this is this is a cause of immense shame and meanwhile in the south are people called the cushites who are kind of nubian kingdom yeah who again the egyptians have
崩溃成了一个无政府状态的国家，有许多不同的国王，这被埃及人视为一件可怕的事情。然后他们恢复过来，建立了所谓的中古王国。中古王国随后又再次崩溃，嗯，大约在公元前1630年，而屈辱在于，埃及北部地区——包括金字塔，包括孟菲斯的古代首都——被外国人征服了。而这些外国人来自巴勒斯坦、迦南，无论你怎么称呼它。这是一场不可容忍的羞辱，因为埃及人极其排外，极度意识到自己优越于周围的所有人，所以这是产生巨大耻辱的原因，与此同时，在南部是一群被称为库什人的人，他们有点像努比亚王国，是的，埃及人也
periodically been going off and kicking sand in their faces and forcing unfair trade deals on them and establishing forts along the stretches of the Nile that runs through Cush. They also get a bit uppity and they start kind of kicking the Egyptians around. So I think the parallel would be imagine Byzantium, the Roman Empire in the 7th century. You've lost Rome. You've lost the western half to barbarians. And then you have the Arabs who previously had been subject to the Romans and they've nicked vast swathes of Roman provinces. And all you've got is Byzantium. peoples, you have the Kushites to the south, and you have the remnants of the Egyptian state in what comes to be called Thebes, what's now Luxor. And there's no guarantee that they're necessarily going to recover, but they do, thanks to the emergence of a succession of remarkable kings and of remarkable
定期去挑衅他们，骑在他们头上拉屎，强加不公平的贸易协议给他们，并在穿过库什的尼罗河流域沿线建立堡垒。他们也变得有点自大，开始欺负埃及人。所以我想，这可以类比为想象拜占庭，7世纪的罗马帝国。你失去了罗马。你失去了西部给蛮族。然后你有了以前曾受制于罗马人的阿拉伯人，他们抢占了罗马省份的大片土地。而你拥有的只有拜占庭。各个部族，南部的库什人，以及在后来被称为底比斯（也就是现在的卢克索）的埃及国残余势力。并没有什么保证他们一定会复苏，但他们确实做到了，这要归功于一连串杰出的国王和杰出的
queens. And that's what's so fascinating about it. So sometimes, Tom, we get some comments from listeners. So actually some from quite sort of longstanding listeners, and they say, we wish you could do more powerful women, women with agency, women who aren't just being kicked around by men or seen through men's eyes and so on. And you could argue, couldn't you, that Hatshepsut, who we'll come to after we've done the context, that she's one of the most outstanding early examples. Absolutely, yes. Of a woman with real imperial agency. Well, her name literally means the foremost of noble women. And I guess that that's a very accurate description. I mean, she is incredibly formidable and able leader. I mean, it is obviously very, very unusual for women to rule. The Egyptians don't have a word for queen. All women are defined in terms of their relationship to the king. So the mother of the king, the end of the Middle Kingdom. But otherwise, the idea that a
女王的涌现。这就是最引人入胜的地方。所以有时候，汤姆，我们会收到一些听众的评论。实际上，有些是相当资深的听众，他们说，希望你们能多讲讲更有权势的女性，有自主权的女性，而不是只被男人践踏或从男人的视角来看待的女性等等。你可以说，不是吗，哈特谢普苏特——我们在讲完背景后就会讲到她——她是早期最杰出的典范之一。绝对是的，一个拥有真正帝国自主权的女性。嗯，她的名字字面意思就是“最高贵的女性”。我想这是一个非常准确的描述。我的意思是，她是一位极其令人生畏且有能力的领导者。我的意思是，女性统治显然是非常非常罕见的。埃及人没有“女王”这个词。所有女性都是根据她们与国王的关系来定义的。所以国王的母亲，中古王国的末期。但除此之外，
woman could rule as king was obviously, you know, it generated all kinds of tensions. So Hatshepsut in that sense is a real innovator, but she's not coming from nowhere. And her forebears, so the succession of extraordinary warrior pharaohs who first of all, they conquer the territory that's lost, and they then expand northwards into the Near East and southwards back into Kush. So they are very formidable militarists in the classic sense of a male pharaoh, but they are surrounded by incredibly formidable women who often serve as regents. Those are the two traditions that Hatshepsut is drawing on.
女性作为国王统治的观念显然是，你知道的，它引发了各种各样的紧张关系。所以在某种意义上，哈特谢普苏特是一位真正的革新者，但她并非凭空出现。她的先辈，也就是一连串非凡的武士法老，他们首先征服了失去的领土，然后向北扩展到近东，向南重新扩展回库什。因此，他们是以男性法老的经典意义上的非常可怕的军事家，但他们被极其可怕的女性所包围，这些女性通常担任摄政王。这就是哈特谢普苏特所借鉴的两个传统。
The idea that Egypt is a great power, but also this idea that women do absolutely have agency in this period. Right. Okay. So I know you want to talk a little bit about the context, don't you years before the birth of christ yeah so greece and rome are nothing yeah and egypt has been through this terrible sort of um you know it's been relegated basically well it's it's struggling to it's yes it's been it's been relegated to the leagues and it's struggling to avoid going into receivership it's west brahmachalbian you know it's it's a constant threat and then you it comes back. Egypt comes back. So the Hyksos, who are these Asiatic kings who have established themselves in the north of Egypt, obviously they start to adopt Egyptian customs and practices, but they always remain self-consciously foreign. They have temples to their own gods. They practice their own fashions. The reason that they've been so successful is that they have a new military weapon, namely the chariot. And it takes time for the Egyptians to adopt that. But in due course of, you know, the famous image of Tutankhamen in his chariot or Ramesses,
埃及是一个大国的理念，但同时也有女性在这个时期绝对拥有自主权的理念。好的，好的。所以，我知道你想稍微谈谈背景，对吧，在基督诞生之前的好多年，是的，所以希腊和罗马什么都不是，是的，埃及经历了这种可怕的，嗯，你知道的，它基本上被降级了，嗯，它，它在努力，是的，它，它被降级到低级别联赛，它在努力避免进入破产接管状态，它是西布朗维奇（保级球队），你知道的，这是一个持续的威胁，然后它回来了。埃及回来了。所以喜克索斯人，这些在埃及北部建立政权的亚洲国王，显然他们开始采用埃及的风俗习惯，但他们始终自视甚外。他们为自己的神灵建造神庙。他们奉行自己的时尚。他们之所以如此成功，是因为他们拥有一个新的军事武器，即战车。埃及人需要时间来适应这一点。但在适当的时候，你知道的，图坦卡蒙驾着战车的著名形象，或者拉美西斯
the great whatever, the chariot will become a kind of defining emblem of the pharaoh. And so it takes time for the Egyptians down in Thebes to kind of develop that. But they do, they start to adopt Hyksos weapons, which are much more kind of formidable than the traditional Egyptian weaponry. And by, well, by the kind of the 1540s, they're starting to launch attacks northwards. So there's one king who seems to be quite successful, then he gets very brutally killed in battle the the autopsy on him is is horrible the arms and hands were left in the agonized attitude into which they had been thrown in the death spasms following the murderous attack the evidence of which is so clearly impressed on the battered face and skull so tom where's where's that from like who wrote
大帝等等，战车将成为法老的一种标志性象征。因此，底比斯的埃及人需要时间来发展这一点。但他们确实做到了，他们开始采用喜克索斯人的武器，这比传统的埃及武器要强大得多。到了，嗯，大约在公元前1540年代，他们开始向北发动进攻。所以有一位国王似乎相当成功，然后他在战斗中被极其残酷地杀死，对他的尸体的解剖是可怕的，手臂和双手留在了在谋杀袭击之后的死亡痉挛中扭曲的痛苦姿态中，这种袭击的证据如此清晰地印在遭到殴打的脸庞和头骨上。所以，汤姆，这，这是从哪里来的？就像是谁写
that down so that's the auto that's the autopsist who does it who look is looking at this guy king's mummy oh right so the body has been brought back from the battle and he's you know it's it's also hurried that that they can't kind of even out the limbs they just mummify him and chuck him in his grave because they're in you know the exigencies of war being what they are but that king's son a guy called Kamos, he's much more successful. So he boasts that his army goes like a great blast of fire, that he approaches the Hyksos king in his palace and makes wine from the Hyksos king's vines and drinks it before his palace. And basically, you're having the sense there that things are starting to tick up for the Egyptians. And Kamos is succeeded by a bloke called Amos, who might be either his son or his brother. And it's absolutely typical of the state of our knowledge that, you know,
下来的？所以那是，那是进行解剖的人写的，他正在看着这个家伙的国王木乃伊，哦，对了，所以尸体是从战场运回来的，然后他，你知道的，它太匆忙了，以至于他们甚至无法把肢体摆平，他们只是把他做成木乃伊然后扔进坟墓，因为他们正处于，你知道的，战争的紧迫情况就是这样，但那个国王的儿子，一个叫卡摩斯的人，他要成功得多。所以他吹嘘说他的军队就像一阵大火，他走近喜克索斯国王的宫殿，用喜克索斯国王的葡萄园酿酒，并在他的宫殿前饮用。基本上，你从这里能感觉到，埃及人的情况开始好转了。卡摩斯之后是一个叫阿世斯（阿赫摩斯）的人继位，他可能是他的儿子也可能是他的弟弟。而这完全符合我们知识现状的典型情况，你知道的，
Egyptologists devote entire books to arguing over these kinds of details. I was just trying to work out a way in which, is it possible he could be both? But I don't think it is. There's a bit of intermarriage, isn't there? There's a bit of the sort of Ptolemy style. Yes, absolutely. And there is indeed quite a lot of intermarriage.
埃及古学家们花费整本书的篇幅来争论这些细节。我刚才只是在想办法，他有没有可能是两者的结合？但我觉得不可能。里面有一点通婚，不是吗？有一点托勒密风格的通婚。是的，绝对的。事实上确实有很多通婚。
Partly because, and it's chiefly down to Amos, actually, this extraordinary king who does this. He absolutely centres the idea of the king and his family as being at the heart of the state. And he's able to do that because it's Amos who finally expels the Hyksos from Egypt. So he storms their palaces and their fortresses in the north. And he then pursues them through Sinai into Canaan. And he captures all kinds of fortresses. So he renames the great fortress of gaza the town that pharaoh seized right which is very descriptive um does what it says on the tin and then he goes southwards and
部分原因在于——这主要归功于阿赫摩斯，实际上，这位做出这一壮举的非凡国王。他绝对将国王及其家人是国家核心的理念置于中心地位。他能够做到这一点，是因为正是阿赫摩斯最终将喜克索斯人驱逐出了埃及。因此，他攻占了他们在北部的宫殿和堡垒。然后他通过西奈半岛一路追击他们进入迦南。他夺取了各种各样的堡垒。所以他重新命名了加沙的伟大堡垒——“法老夺取的城镇”，这非常具有描述性，嗯，名副其实，然后他向南进发，
he um he conquers kush and kush is that this is very important because kush produces lots of gold and amos basically is the model of a great conqueror and so because of that, he can legitimately portray himself and his family as being absolutely the beating heart of this newly recreated great power that is Egypt. And so therefore, it is important for him to basically keep things within the family so that he marries his sister. So his sister is Ahotep. Is that right? No, Ahotep is his mother. Okay. So Ahotep is a very, very big cheese. So she, in the best traditions of the new kingdom, incredibly boastful.
他，嗯，他征服了库什。而库什，这非常重要，因为库什出产大量的黄金，阿赫摩斯基本上是一个伟大征服者的模范，因此正因为如此，他可以合情合理地将自己和他的家人描绘成刚刚重建的、埃及这个大国的绝对跳动的心脏。因此，对她而言，基本上把事情留在家族内部是很重要的，所以他娶了他的姐姐。所以他的姐姐是阿霍特普。是这样吗？不，阿霍特普是他的母亲。好吧。所以阿霍特普是个非常非常重要的人物。因此，在新王国的最佳传统中，她极其自大。
So she give praise to the lady of the land. You know, this is written on one of her inscriptions. The mistress of the shores of Haunebet, whose reputation is high over every foreign land, who governs the masses the wise one who guards over egypt and interestingly you said greece and rome you know not on the scene but there is a theory that how nebet is um it might be crete because she is buried with a cretan axe and a cretan dagger right so uh there's a sense that you know at the foreign court they're interested in looking abroad and adopting foreign fashions.
所以她“向大地女主人致敬”。你知道，这是写在她的一块铭文上的。“豪内贝特海岸的女主人，其声誉高过每一片异国土地，她统治着大众，守护着埃及的智者。”有趣的是，你刚才提到希腊和罗马，你知道的，不在现场，但有一种理论认为豪内贝特是，嗯，可能是克里特岛，因为她下葬时带着一把克里特战斧和一把克里特匕首，对吧？所以，嗯，有一种感觉，你知道的，在外国宫殿里，他们对外出很感兴趣，并采用外国时尚。
So that would be Minoan, wouldn't it? Yeah, so that would be Minoan. So Ahotep is the mother and she had ruled actually as regent for Ahmos. Ahmos marries his sister, who infuriatingly is also called Ahmos. Oh, yes. Ahmos Nefertari. So it's not, you know, it's not enough that the brothers and sisters are marrying, but they're actually called the same. So it's potentially incredibly confusing. But she also, so again, when the male Ahmose dies, the female Ahmose, let's call her Ahmose Nefertari, that's her her full name right she uh she then rules as regent for their son who's a young boy called amenhotep and so she she effectively is you know she she doesn't call herself the king
所以那是米诺斯文明，对吧？是的，所以那是米诺斯文明。所以阿霍特普是母亲，她实际上曾担任阿赫摩斯的摄政王。阿赫摩斯娶了他的姐姐，令人恼火的是，她也叫阿赫摩斯。哦，是的，阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉。所以，这不仅仅是，你知道的，兄弟姐妹在结婚，而且他们实际上叫同一个名字。所以这可能令人难以置信地困惑。但她也，所以再次当男性阿赫摩斯去世时，女性阿赫摩斯——让我们称她为阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉，那是她的全名，对吧——她，然后作为摄政王统治他们的儿子，一个名叫阿蒙霍特普的小男孩。所以她实际上，你知道的，她不称自己为国王，
but she is ruling in the place of the king but that's why it's interesting right that she rules in the place but she doesn't yeah is that because at that point they have no you know you said there had been a uh one female king i don't want to say queen because that implies a consort. No, she's not a queen. So there'd been one female king back in the mists of time. About 200 years before. So not in the mists of time. In the memory, in people's memory.
但她以国王的身份在统治。但这就是为什么这很有趣，对吧？她以国王的身份统治，但她没有，嗯？是因为在那时他们没有，你知道的，你刚才说过曾有过一个，嗯，一个女国王——我不想用“女王”，因为那暗示着配偶。不，她不是女王。所以早在时间的迷雾中就曾有过一位女国王。大约早了200年。所以不是在时间的迷雾中。在记忆中，在人们的记忆中。
Do people remember that, would you say? I don't think it's hugely, it's not a huge thing. They're not chatting about it in the pubs of Thebes. I mean, Hatshepsut, of course, in due course, will make quite a huge thing i mean i'm not chatting about it no they're not no they're not pubs of thebes i mean hatchets of course in due course will make quite a big thing of it but right i don't think it's particularly so when when when our most male dies and our most female comes in as regent yeah it doesn't occur to her and nobody's saying oh why don't you take the throne it's just not an option no but so you've had for two successive generations you've had women ruling as regents for underage kings right you've had a hotep yeah ruling for ahmos and then you've
人们还记得那个吗，你会这么说吗？我不认为这是一个巨大的事情，这不是一件大事。他们不会在底比斯的酒馆里聊起这个。我的意思是，哈特谢普苏特，当然，在适当的时候，会把这搞成一件相当大的事情，我的意思是，我不是在聊这个，不，他们没有，不，他们没有在底比斯的酒馆里，我的意思是，哈特谢普苏特，当然，在适当的时候，会把这搞成一件相当大的事情，但是，对，我不认为这特别——所以当男性阿赫摩斯去世，女性阿赫摩斯作为摄政王进来时，是的，这并没有出现在她的脑海里，也没有人说“哦，你为什么不登上王座呢”，这根本不是一个选项。不，但是你连续两代都有女性作为未成年国王的摄政王统治，对吧？你曾有阿霍特普，是的，为阿赫摩斯统治，然后你曾有阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉为他们的儿子阿蒙霍特普统治，我认为这奠定了这样一种观念，即女性，你知道的，非常非常能够统治埃及，嗯。但它没有做的是确立一个女性可以作为国王统治的观念。基本上总是必须有某个人是她站在其背后的，是的，基本上。但阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉极其有效，正是在她的摄政期间以及哈森·阿蒙霍特普的统治期间，你开始在底比斯看到一个非常显著的发展。所以底比斯在尼罗河东岸，被视为生者之地，而在西岸，死者之地，因为那是太阳落山的地方，他们开始建造纪念神庙——为纪念国王而兴建的神庙，很有可能正是在这个时候，将成为帝王谷的地方
had ahmos nefertari ruling for their son amenotep and i think that that kind of beds down the idea that women you know are very very able to govern egypt yeah um but what it doesn't do is establish the idea that a woman can rule as king there always has to be somebody that she's standing behind basically yeah basically but amos nefertari is incredibly effective and it's during her regency and the rule of hasan amenotep that that you start to get a very significant development at thebes so so thebes is on the east bank of the nile which is seen as the land of the living and on the western bank the land of the dead because that's where the sun sets they start to build mortuary temples temples that are being raised to the memory of the kings and very possibly this is when what will become the valley of the kings
开始受到尊重。所以这种理念，即你拥有生者之地——这将成为右侧伟大的卡纳克神庙——而在左侧你拥有死者之地的维度，阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉正在主持这一切。这些人可不是金字塔建造者，对吧？我的意思是，认为我们把所有古埃及混为一谈的人，金字塔是几个世纪甚至几千年以前的事了。是的，是的。他们基本上已经弄明白了这样一个事实：如果你不想让你的，你知道的，财宝从你的陵墓里被偷走，用一座巨大的金字塔来做广告，并不是一个明智的做法。在适当的时候，哈特谢普苏特的纪念神庙将成为其中最著名的一座，它建在这个山脊的一侧，
start to be respected so this idea that you have the land of the living which will become the great temple of karnak on on the right side and on the left side you have this dimension of the dead this is ahmos nefertari is presiding over that and and this these people are not pyramid builders are they i mean people who think that the we conflate all ancient egypt into one sort of mass the pyramids were were centuries and centuries before yeah yeah and they've basically twigged the fact that if you don't want to have your you know your treasure nicked from your from your tomb kind of advertising it with a huge pyramid is is not a sensible way to do that and in due course the mortuary temples of which hapshuts will be the most famous is built on one side of this mountain ridge
而帝王谷则隐蔽地位于它后面的山谷里，对吧？所以这就是阿赫摩斯·纳菲尔塔莉作为摄政王和她的儿子阿蒙霍特普正在进行的事情。但问题是近亲结婚，因为近亲结婚不好，对吧，对于生育能力而言？你懂的，你对科学和遗传学的喜爱，你会知道的——我不知道我要去哪，我不知道你要带向何方——你对遗传学的了解。所以基本上，阿蒙霍特普，阿蒙霍特普没有孩子，没有儿子，是的，所以这仍然在遭受这种指控，我必须说，所以这是一个问题，嗯，因为他们需要一个国王，所以他环顾四周，他收养了——狗，规矩点！——他收养了，嗯，某个似乎
and then the valley of the kings lies in the discreetly in the valley behind it right so that's that's going on with um akmos nefertari as regent and her son amenotep but the problem is the incest because uh incest is not good is it for fertility you will know that your fondness for science and genetics you will know that i don't know where i wonder where you're going with that your knowledge of genetics so so basically aminotep does aminotep has no children has no sons yeah and so this is still reeling from this accusation i have to say and so this is a problem uh because they need a king and so he looks around and he he adopted the dog behave yourself he adopts um someone who who seems to
是远亲，并且绝对是那种大军阀、朝廷中最受信赖的心腹的人。那是一个叫图特摩斯的人，对吧？是的，听众们会很高兴地得知，这个故事里有数量惊人的名叫图特摩斯的人。所以，同样，你只需要，这总归是好的，你只需要掌握好——所以这是图特摩斯一世，好吧，他是一个绝对了不起的小伙子。他是个军人。他是一个到处横冲直撞的军人。他的绰号是“黑豹”。“黑豹”。是的。
have been a distant relative and was definitely the kind of the big military man the most trusted lieutenant at the court it was a guy called thutmose right yes and listeners will be delighted to know that there are an enormous number of people called thutmose in this story so again you just need to that's always good you just need to keep a handle so this is thutmose the first okay and he is an absolutely tremendous lad he's a military man he is a military man who just rampages around. His nickname is the Panther. The Panther. Yes.
因为他扑向猎物、残害并杀死它们。是的，但我认为黑豹应该是那种难以捉摸、安静、鬼鬼祟祟的。如果他在喝酒大喊大叫，他就一点也不符合这些。嗯，他是一只吵闹的黑豹。好吧。他是一只喜欢喝酒的黑豹。好吧。我喜欢这个。
Because he pounces and savages and kills. Yeah, but I think of a panther as kind of elusive and quiet, stealthy. He's none of those things if he's boozing and shouting. Well, he's a loud panther. Okay. He's a panther who likes a drink. Okay. I like that.
我在试图想一个现代的类比，但我想不出来。嗯，所以他极其成功。是的。对法老而言，成功的标准在此时基本上似乎是军事上的。是的。所以这几乎成了一个传统：你成为法老，然后你咆哮着向北冲去，痛打迦南的所有人，他非常成功地做到了这一点。是的。还有就是你向南进发，攻击库什人，图特摩斯一世对付库什人的战绩非常非常好。
I'm trying to think of a modern analogy and I can't. Well, so he's incredibly successful. Yeah. And the measure of success is for a pharaoh basically at this point seems to be military. Yeah. So it's pretty much become a tradition that you become pharaoh and then you go roaring off north and you beat up all the people in Canaan, which he does very successfully. Yeah. And also that you you go south and you attack the cushites and thutmose the first does very very well against the cushites
所以他攻占了他们的首都——一个叫做克尔玛的地方，他洗劫并烧毁了它。他到达了这块巨大的石英岩——这是一种，你知道的，极其闪亮的矿物岩石。这对库什人来说非常神圣，他们竖起了各种各样的宗教铭文。他把这些全部抹掉，竖起了一块巨大的、自我吹嘘的关于他自己的铭文。他在尼罗河沿线建立了许多堡垒，这些堡垒有着传统的埃及名字，比如“无人敢与他对抗”、“我是个天才”以及“去你的吧，库什人”。对吧。你知道，所有这些类似的名字。他只是到处留下铭文，吹嘘自己，你知道的，做得多么出色。所以那里没有留下一个努比亚人。
so he captures their capital a place called kerma um he sacks and burns it he reaches this great rock of courts it's kind of you know, incredibly shiny kind of mineral rock. Which has been very holy to the Kushites and they put up all kinds of religious inscriptions. And he erases the lot and puts up an enormous kind of self-glorifying inscription to himself. He founds forts all along the line of the Nile, which have traditional Egyptian names like No One Dares Confront Him and I Am Brilliant and Screw You Kushites. Right. You know, all these kinds of names. And he just leaves inscriptions everywhere boasting about, you know, how brilliantly he's done. So there is not a single Nubian left there.
弓箭手在大屠杀中倒下，尸体横陈在他们的祖国。他们的内脏浸透了山谷的鲜血，从口中倾泻而下。他把被他杀死的努比亚国王、库什国王的尸体取下来，将它绑在努比亚国王、他杀死的库什国王的船头，当他航行回去，嗯，顺流而下，顺流而回，头部朝下，所以尸体慢慢腐烂，被苍蝇吃掉，这是一场极其惊人、极其壮观的展示。
Bowmen have fallen amid the slaughter and lies corpses across their native land. Their entrails drench the valley's blood, pours in torrents from their mouths. He takes the body of the Nubian king who he's killed, the Cushite king, and he lashes it to the prow of the nubian king who he's killed the kushite king and he lashes it to the the prow of his ship as he sails back up um the uh back back up the head head down and so the body slowly rotting getting eaten by flies it's tremendous tremendous
然后他径直向北，他攻击了一个叫做米坦尼王国的王国，这是叙利亚北部、伊拉克北部、南部（现在南土耳其南部）的一个有抱负的大国。在那里赢得了一场伟大的大战，竖起了一块铭文，并通过去猎象来超越了自己。所以你可以看到，他，你知道的，他是个重量级人物。他的确是，汤姆，我不会掩饰这一点。所以图特摩斯一世，他是哈特谢普苏特的父亲。对吧。哈特谢普苏特对他十分崇拜。而原因之一，也许是当他去库什远征时，他把哈特谢普苏特——当时她一定还是个小女孩——带在身边。所以她亲眼目睹了爸爸的行动。她见证了埃及军队的伟大。她明白了什么是成为一个强大的国王、一个强大的统治者。这些似乎是她铭记于心的教训。哈特谢普苏特是图特摩斯正妻的女儿。所以这是一位具有王室血统的女王。图特摩斯一世与一个地位较低的妻子生有一个儿子，也叫图特摩斯，
display and then he goes right north and he he attacks a kingdom called the uh the kingdom of the mitanni which is um a kind of aspirant great power in northern syria northern iraq southern what's now southern turkey wins a great battle there erects an inscription and excels himself there by going on an elephant hunt so you can see that he he you know he's he's a big hitter he is i like him tom i won't i won't hide it so thutmose the first he is the father of Hatshepsut. Right. And Hatshepsut is devoted to him. And one of the reasons for this, perhaps, is that when he went on his expedition into Kush, he took Hatshepsut, who at this point must have been quite a young girl, with him. So she has seen daddy in action. She has seen the greatness of the
所以当他去世时，图特摩斯二世继位并娶了哈特谢普苏特，对吧？但那里存在权力失衡，因为哈特谢普苏特的血统比图特摩斯二世高贵得多，但另一方面他是个男人，所以大概他自然而然地获得了某种尊重，而这种尊重可能是她从男人们、其他男人、士兵、朝臣或任何人那里得不到的。但血统就是一切吗？我的意思是，我想那就是——显而易见，男人统治比女人统治更重要，这就是为什么尽管哈特谢普苏特的血统更有威望，是的，她是国王的妻子，从这个程度来说，她是一个传统的人物，但她是一个有权势的人物，她是一个重量级人物。相比之下，图特摩斯二世似乎有点像个废物，对吧？我觉得他一开始相当年轻。关于他究竟统治了多久存在混淆，一些学者说三年，一些学者说13年，但他似乎没有什么伟大的军事履历。去痛打库什人的远征，他似乎并没有亲自领导。因此，图特摩斯二世和哈特谢普苏特确实有一个孩子，但那是个女儿，名叫妮菲鲁拉。
Egyptian army. She has seen what it is to be a mighty king, a mighty ruler. And these are lessons that she seems to have taken in. And Hatshepsut is the daughter of Thutmose's principal wife. So this is a queen who is of royal descent. Thutmose I has a son by a lesser wife, also called Thutmose and so when he dies Thutmose the second succeeds and marries Hatshepsut right but there is a power imbalance there because Hatshepsut's line of descent is much more regal than Thutmose the second but on the other hand he is a man so presumably he commands automatic deference in a way that she perhaps doesn't from the men the other men the soldiers the courtiers whatever but is blood all i mean i suppose that's the it's clearly more important that a man rules
所以她显然不在继承序列中。图特摩斯二世还有一个儿子——不可避免地也叫图特摩斯——是一个地位较低的妻子生的。所以他某种程度上处于继承的有利位置。当他去世时，此时哈特谢普苏特可能十几岁快二十岁，甚至可能二十出头。所以她介入了，扮演摄政王的角色。这是一个常规角色。这并没有什么太出奇的。在她之前两代人就已经发生过这种事了。但接下来发生的事情确实非同寻常，并使哈特谢普苏特得以被铭记为有史以来最卓越的统治者之一。你觉得我们是不是该在这个时候休息一下？我想针对那个惊人的说法，汤姆，那个惊人的说法，我们休息一下，然后回来，
than a woman which is why despite the fact that hapshitzut's line of descent is is more prestigious yeah she is the wife of the king so to that extent she is a conventional figure but she's a powerful figure she's she's she's a big player and thutmose the second by contrast seems to have been a bit of a weed right i think he's quite young to begin with there's confusion as to exactly how long he reigned some some scholars say three years some say 13 years but he doesn't seem to have had a great military track record the expeditions to go and beat up the kushites he doesn't seem to have led them in person. So Thutmose II and Hatshepsut, they do have a child, but it's a daughter, Nefererere.
听汤姆·霍兰德解释为什么哈特谢普苏特是有史以来最伟大的统治者之一。所以休息后加入我们。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，
So she is obviously not in line to succeed. Thutmose II has also had a son, inevitably called Thutmose, by a lesser wife. And so he's kind of in pole position to succeed. And when he dies, by this point, Hatshepsut is probably late teens, maybe even early 20s. And so she steps in, in the role as regent. And that's a conventional thing. You know, there's nothing too out of the ordinary. This has happened kind of two generations before her. But it's what happens next that really is extraordinary and that enables Hatshepsut to be commemorated as one of the most remarkable rulers who's ever lived. And do you think we should take a break at this point? I think on that enormous claim, Tom, that enormous claim, we'll take a break and we will return
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。没有人比她更美丽。她的光彩和外表犹如神明。她是一位精致而绽放的少女。这正是汤姆·霍兰德对历史上最伟大的世界领袖之一——埃及法老哈特谢普苏特的描述。而这段描述，汤姆，是哈特谢普苏特本人写的。好吧，在埃及，谦逊并不被视为一种美德。
for Tom Holland to justify why Hatshepsut is one of the greatest rulers who has ever lived. So join us after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
这就像跟《The Rest Is History》的主持人谈论他们自己的播客一样，不是吗？这就是他们中的某个人可能会在《每日邮报》上写自己的那种东西。确实如此。是的。这挺有意思的，因为它确实吸引了人们的注意力：试图掌握古埃及历史人物个性的一大难题在于，他们被描绘的方式往往倾向于刻板印象，而且，很难知道这是否真的是对她的准确描述。所以根据她家人的木乃伊——他们似乎都相当矮，你知道的，带有一种轻微的拿破仑式的特质。根据对他们肖像的分析，有人认为他们似乎有着相当大的鼻子，对吧，所以——所以有人认为这就是，而且我们并不确定我们拥有哈特谢普苏特的木乃伊，所以我们，是的，我们不能以此为证据。但她的许多亲戚似乎都有暴牙。但这未免太苛刻了吧，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你留给后世的所有痕迹都消失了，而我们是从你表亲的木乃伊之类的东西来推断的话。
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com There was no one more beautiful. Her splendor and her appearance were divine. She was a maiden, exquisite and blooming. Now that is a description of, for Tom Holland, one of the greatest of all world leaders in history, the Egyptian pharaoh Hatshepsut. And that description, Tom, was written by Hatshepsut herself. Well, modesty wasn't really accounted a virtue in Egypt.
我知道，我知道，我知道。为这种整体氛围添砖加瓦的是乔伊斯·蒂尔德斯利在她那本精彩的书《女法老哈特谢普苏特》中提出的论点，她提出了哈特谢普苏特很可能是个光头——光头？嗯，因为他们剃光了头，男女都一样，好吧，这就是为什么他们戴假发，对吧，所以她可能个子矮、大鼻子、暴牙还有点秃。除此之外，非常性感。她是怎么评价自己的？是的。
It's like talking to the presenters of The Rest is History about their own podcast, isn't it? It's the kind of thing that one of them might write in the Daily Mail about himself. It is indeed. Yes. And it's kind of interesting because it does draw attention to the way in which one of the problems with getting a handle on the personalities of figures from ancient Egyptian history is that the way that they're portrayed tends to be done in terms of stereotype and, you know, difficult to know whether this is actually an accurate description of her so based on the mummies uh of of her family they all seem to have been quite
没有人比她更美丽。她的光彩和外表犹如神明。我赞同这一点，事实上，汤姆。是的。她显然是一个极具个人魅力的女性。我的意思是，毫无疑问。就在我们进入她的统治之前，既然你建议我们用她对自己的描述来作为切入点，这其实是个很好的方式来谈谈：我们究竟是如何了解这些历史人物的任何事情的？难道全靠象形文字铭文吗？我们是在拼命地进行，我们是在把推测建立在推测之上，基本上。是的。好吧，我记得你讲都铎王朝时提到过简·格雷女士，说什么来着，她走过一丛灌木之类的。凯瑟琳·霍华德走过一丛灌木之类的。英国园艺之母。一大堆。所以确实有那么一点点这种成分。
short you know slight kind of napoleonic quality to them it's been argued on the basis of analysis of their portraits that they seem to have had quite big noses right so right so so it has been argued that this was and definitely we don't definitely have hatchet so it's mummy so we yeah we don't can't use that as evidence. But quite a lot of her relatives seem to have had buck teeth. This is harsh, though, isn't it? I mean, if all trace of you was lost to posterity, and we were extrapolating from the mummies of your cousins or something.
而使情况更加复杂的是，当然，通常我们甚至不知道，你知道，我们甚至不能确定，你知道，一个妻子是一个姐姐。一个姐姐可能是一个妻子，或者有各种各样的复杂情况。他们都有相同的名字。这非常非常困难。但对于哈特谢普苏特，我认为因为她是如此与众不同，她的所作所为是如此不寻常，国王通常被描绘的方式与现实之间的张力足够强烈，
I know, I know, I know. And adding to the general vibe uh is the the thesis that joyce tardsley in her brilliant book hatchets of the female pharaoh and she advances the the idea that hatchets that might well have been bald bald well because they did they shaved their heads men and women okay and you know that's why they wore the wigs right um so she might be have been small big nose with buck teeth and ball. But apart from that, very hot. What did she say of herself? Yeah.
以至于你基本上可以推断出她在做什么。我的意思是，这正是她如此有趣的原因。所以你在前半部分结束时留下了一个小悬念，因为你说她正准备做一件绝对非同寻常的事。我想从她的行动中，我们可以窥见她的一点性格。那么她到底做了什么如此非同寻常的事呢？所以她的丈夫兼同父异母的兄弟已经去世，留下了一个并非正宫王后所生的儿子。因此，撇开他的性别不谈，他的地位比哈特谢普苏特本人要低。是的。而且他还是个很小的婴儿。
There was no one more beautiful. Her splendor and her appearance were divine. I go with that, actually, Tom. Yeah. She's clearly a woman of immense charisma. I mean, there's no doubt about that. Just before we get into her reign, and since you suggested that we use our own description of
从一开始，哈特谢普苏特就承认他为国王。而她自己的角色一开始似乎是摄政王。所以图特摩斯——也就是后来成为图特摩斯三世的人——的角色，对于那里究竟发生了什么，实际上有两种选择：要么哈特谢普苏特作为摄政王统治，是因为她别无选择，因为图特摩斯是，是唯一显而易见的人选，你知道，图特摩斯三世是唯一的候选人，是的，所以她在逆境中做到最好；但也可以从另一个角度来看，那就是她想要统治，她觉得她有权统治，她有能力，她能干，她的血管里流淌着正确的血液，因此她把这个小婴儿当作某种幌子、傀儡，一个可以，你知道的，她可以把他当作前台，将权力的缰绳抓在自己手里。所以这两种选择都是可能的。而我猜后者是，你知道的，在某种程度上两者兼而有之。我的意思是，我们无从得知。
herself, it's a really good way to actually talk about how do we know anything about any of these people? Is it all from hieroglyphic inscriptions? And we are desperately trying to sort of, we're piling conjecture on conjecture, basically. Yeah. Well, I remember you saying about Tudor when we did Lady Jane Grey and saying that, what was it, that she walked past a bush or something. Catherine Howard walked past a bush or something. The mother of English gardening. Great piles. So there is a slight element of that.
是的，她可能最初是出于权宜之计。然后几个月或几年后觉得，你知道吗，我其实挺擅长这个的。是的，所以我们不知道。我们不知道她从一开始是否就旨在将自己确立为国王。是的。但很明显，她正在做的事情是在逐步地将自己推向一个可以被欢呼为国王的位置。一开始，她不仅是摄政王，她还是阿蒙之妻。而阿蒙是神明之王。最初，他只是一个驻扎在底比斯的不重要的地区神。但因为他是这个伟大武士王朝的保护神，
And what adds to the complication, of course, is that often we don't even, you know, we can't even be certain that, you know, a wife is a sister. A sister might be a wife or having all kinds of complications. They all have the same names. It is very, very difficult. But with Hapshetzut, I think because she's so unusual, and what she does is so unusual, the strains that exist between the way that kings are conventionally portrayed and the actual reality is sufficiently strong
这个王朝崛起并征服了整个埃及，并将自己立为全埃及的国王，他被尊奉为至高无上的神，因此他的角色与传统的众神之王——拉——模糊地结合在了一起。所以阿蒙-拉——哦，是的，确切地说——所以他们实际上融为一体了，不是吗？是的，所以你拥有了这座宏伟的神庙，你知道的，也就是现在的卡纳克，任何去过卢克索的人都会看到它，它算得上是，可能绝对算得上是世界伟大的旅游景点之一。我的意思是，它绝对是一个令人瞠目结舌的神社、方尖碑、柱子以及各种事物的结合体。它是在第十八王朝期间建造的。哈特谢普苏特以阿蒙之妻的身份，基本上与阿蒙的大祭司共事。我的意思是，她负责那一切。而且它是如此富有，如此——我敢说——神圣，以至于她立即拥有了一个不可思议的
that you can kind of work out what she's doing. I mean, that's what makes her so interesting. So you ended the first half on a bit of a cliffhanger because you said she was poised to do something absolutely extraordinary. And I guess from her actions, we can divine a little bit of her character. So what is it that she does that is so remarkable? So her husband stroke half- half brother has died and has left a son who is not descended from the principal queen. So is therefore of lesser rank than Hatshepsut herself, discounting his gender. Yeah. And he's a very small baby.
你可以大致揣摩出她在做什么。我的意思是，这正是她如此有趣的地方。所以上半部分在一个悬念中结束了，因为你说她准备做一件绝对非凡的事。我想从她的行为中，我们可以窥见她的一些性格。那么她到底做了什么如此引人注目呢？她的丈夫兼同父异母的兄弟去世了，留下了一个并非正宫王后所生的儿子。因此，撇开他的性别不谈，他的地位比哈特谢普斯楚本人要低。是的。而且他还是个小婴儿。
And from the beginning, Hatshepsut acknowledges him as a king. And her own role is to begin with, it seems, that of a regent. So the role of Thutmose, who will go on to become Thutmose III, there are really two alternatives as to what is happening there either hatchet so it is ruling as regent because she has no choice because thutmose is is the only obvious you know thutmose the third is the only candidate yeah so she's making the best of a bad job but it's possible to see it in another light which is that she wants to rule she feels she has the right to rule she's able she's competent she has the right blood in her veins and therefore she has fixed on this little baby as a kind of a screen, a patsy, someone who can, you know, she can use him as a front and get all the reins of power in her hands. So both alternatives are possible. And I would guess the latter is, you know, it could be both to a degree. I mean, we can't know.
从一开始，哈特谢普斯楚就承认他为国王。而她自己的角色，起初似乎是摄政。因此对于图特摩斯（日后将成为图特摩斯三世）的角色，当时的情况实际上有两种可能：要么哈特谢普斯楚作为摄政王统治是因为她别无选择，因为图特摩斯是唯一显而易见的人选，也就是图特摩斯三世是唯一的候选人。所以她是在逆境中做出了最好的选择。但也可以从另一个角度来看，那就是她渴望统治，她觉得自己有权统治，她有能力、有才华，她的血统纯正，因此她把这个小婴儿当作一种掩护、一个傀儡，一个她可以利用作为前台并将所有权力大权独揽的人。所以这两种可能都存在。我猜后者也是……某种程度上两兼有之吧。我的意思是，我们无法确切知道。
Yeah, she might have started as an expedient. And then after a few months or years thought, you know what, I'm actually really good at this. Yeah, so we don't know. We don't know whether she aims right from the beginning to establish herself as king. Yeah. But it's evident that what she is doing is incrementally kind of moving herself towards the position where she can be hailed as king. To begin with, she is not only regent, she is also the wife of Amun. And Amun is the king of the gods. Initially, he was a very unimportant regional god based in Thebes. But because he is the patron deity of this great warrior dynasty
是的，她一开始可能只是权宜之计。然后几个月或几年后，她心想，你知道吗，我其实真的很擅长这个。是的，所以我们不得而知。我们不知道她从一开始是不是就旨在确立自己为国王。但显而易见的是，她所做的事是在循序渐进地将自己推向能够被尊为国王的位置。起初，她不仅是摄政王，还是阿蒙神的妻子。阿蒙是众神之王。最初，他只是底比斯一个非常不重要的地区神明。但由于他是这个伟大的武士王朝的守护神
that has emerged and conquered the whole of Egyptgypt and and made themselves kings of of the whole of egypt he gets enshrined as the supreme god and so his role gets blurred with the traditional king of the gods rey so amon rey oh yeah exactly so they they become combined don't they effectively yeah and so you have this great temple what you know what's now karnak anyone who's been to luxor will have seen it it's kind of one of the mean, probably absolutely up there as one of the great tourist sites of the world. I mean, it's absolutely stupefying kind of conglomeration of shrines and obelisks and pillars and all kinds of things. And it gets built over the course of the 18th dynasty. Hatshepsut, in her role as wife of Amun, is basically with the chief priest of Amun. I mean, she is in charge of that. And it's so rich and it's so, dare I say, sacral that immediately she has an incredible
这个王朝崛起并征服了整个埃及，使自己成为全埃及的君王，他被奉为至高无上的神明，因此他的角色与传统众神之王拉融合在了一起——所以是阿蒙-拉，哦，对，完全如此。所以他们实际上结合在了一起，对吧？是的，于是就有了这座伟大的神庙，也就是现在的卡纳克神庙，去过卢克索的人一定都见过它，它堪称世界上最伟大的旅游景点之一。我的意思是，这是一个绝对令人瞠目结舌的圣殿、方尖碑、石柱和各种建筑的综合体。它在第十八王朝期间不断扩建。哈特谢普斯楚作为阿蒙神的妻子，基本上与阿蒙神的大祭司平起平坐。我的意思是，她掌管着这一切。而且它是如此富有，甚至可以说是神圣不可侵犯，以至于她立即拥有了难以置信的
degree of power there. But it's not enough. She wants more. So at some point, maybe five, six, seven years into her regency, she takes on a name that identifies her as as a male king so every every egyptian king takes on what's called a throne name and hatchet so it takes on the name of mart kare so mart is it's kind of truth order the idea that everything is as it should be it's kind of balance isn't it yes balance um and the car is the soul and ray is the king of the gods. Yeah. So truth is the soul of Ray. So that's a really significant development. And then seven years into the regency, again, perhaps a little bit before that, suddenly she's presenting herself as a king. So the crowns, the scepters, the trappings, the sort of...
在那儿拥有一定程度的权力。但那还不够。她想要更多。所以在她摄政大约五、六年、七年后的某个时候，她起了一个新名字，将自己标识为一个男性国王——所以每一个埃及国王都会起所谓的王位名和荷鲁斯名——因此她采用了玛特卡拉（Maatkare）这个名字。玛特（Maat）是一种真理、秩序的理念，意味着一切都应该井然有序，这是一种平衡，对吧？是的，平衡，嗯，“卡”（Ka）是灵魂，而“雷”（Re）是众神之王。是的。所以真理就是雷的灵魂。所以这是一个非常重大的发展。然后在他摄政七年后，或者也许在这之前一点，突然之间，她将自己表现得像一个国王。所以王冠、权杖、装饰，那种……
The false beard. Yeah. The whole works so the false beard just a quick interjection on the false beard because that is one of the things that people who know a tiny bit about this will know the false beard is not that she is passing herself off as a man the false beards because they're common aren't they among for egyptian kings that they will wear these things absolutely so a king is a living symbol. And so you're portrayed in absolutely set ways. And when you manifest yourself in the court or before the people, you are dressed as a symbol,
假胡须。是的。全套装备——关于假胡须，我简单插话一下，因为对于稍微了解一点这方面历史的人来说，假胡须并不是她在伪装成男人，假胡须是因为它们很常见，对吧？在埃及国王中，他们会佩戴这些东西，绝对是的。所以国王是一个活着的象征。因此，你的形象必须以绝对固定的方式被描绘出来。当你出现在朝廷或人民面前时，你穿戴得就像一个象征，
as a symbol of kingship. And that's what Hatshepsut is doing. She wants to conform to every kind of stereotype that is going. The fact that she's a woman in that sense is irrelevant because all kings are to an extent playing a role. The symbolism is more important than the reality. So essentially the reason that the Egyptians are willing to accept her as king seems to be because, precisely because the symbol is more important than the reality yeah that's what enables her to do it but still she's kind of you know no one has has really done it in quite the way that she does it and she does it really really brilliantly so what she does to establish her legitimacy is is that she writes her erstwhile husband half-brother Thutmose the second out of the story you know this kind of wimp who just
作为王权的象征。这就是哈特谢普斯出正在做的事情。她想符合当时存在的各种刻板印象。从这个意义上说，她是女性这件事是无关紧要的，因为所有的国王在某种程度上都在扮演一个角色。象征意义比现实更重要。所以本质上，埃及人愿意接受她为国王的原因似乎正是因为象征意义比现实更重要——是的，正是这一点让她得以做到这一点。但即便如此，你知道的，从来没有人像她那样以这种方式做到这一点，而且她做得非常非常出色。所以，为了确立自己的合法性，她所做的事是，将她曾经的丈夫、同父异母的兄弟图特摩斯二世从历史中抹去——你知道的，这个家伙简直就是个弱者，
gets kind of jettisoned so it appears that she's just got it directly from her father exactly but but then the question is who is her father and that inscription that you read at the beginning right at the start of the episode yeah you know she's she's calling amun the great god the king of the gods yeah her father and so what she does is she promulgates the idea that amun appeared to her mother in the guise of of thutmose the first and the uh you know full-on descriptions of amun's erect penis nice um he he comes bearing the scent of perfumes and fragrance and as the great tide of his desire spills and seeds hatchets at its mother, so the scent of perfume floods the whole palace. It's a bit like the arrival of the milk tray man. Exactly so.
直接被抛弃了，所以看起来她直接从父亲那里继承了王位。完全正确。但随后问题来了，谁是她的父亲？你在节目一开始、一开场时读的那段碑文——是的，你知道的，她称阿蒙这位伟大的神、众神之王——是的——为她的父亲。所以她所做的是，她宣扬了这样一种观念：阿蒙伪装成图特摩斯一世的模样出现在她母亲面前。而且还有……你知道的，对阿蒙勃起阴茎的详尽描述，真不错。嗯，他带着香水和芳香的气味到来，随着他欲望的巨浪喷涌而出，将种子注入哈特谢普斯的母亲体内，香水的芬芳弥漫了整个宫殿。这有点像“奶盘人”（Milk Tray man）的到来。完全是这样。
Exactly so. But of course, what it's not like is like the kind of the Christian idea of becoming yeah pregnant uh this is this is a full-on sex but it's a little bit like the sort of greek myths yes it is a little bit like that i was just thinking about alexander the great he claimed that he was not the son of philip the second yeah but the son of zeus so this is a itself is a formula right i mean absolutely and alexander kind of you know he claims to be the son of Amun as well. So that idea that earthly kings aren't really your father. But it's complicated because at the same time, Hatshepsut is obviously devoted to Thutmose I. So the fact that she's kind of basically saying that Amun cuckolded Thutmose doesn't stop her from very much being you know her father's daughter right yeah very much daddy's girl and so it's this idea that Amun has not only fathered her but has chosen her as king and so you get all these freezes in in the great temple that that Hatshepsut will have
完全是这样。但当然，这不像基督教那种怀孕的观念——是的，这是一场真正的性爱，但它有点像希腊神话。是的，确实有点像那样。我刚刚想到亚历山大大帝，他声称自己不是腓力二世的儿子——是的——而是宙斯的儿子。所以这本身就是一个公式，对吧？我的意思是，绝对是这样。亚历山大也声称自己是阿蒙的儿子。因此，这种世俗君王其实并不是你亲生父亲的观念……但这很复杂，因为与此同时，哈特谢普斯明显对图特摩斯一世充满 devotion（崇敬/忠诚）。所以，她基本上说阿蒙给图特摩斯戴了绿帽子，这并没有妨碍她成为一个地地道道的“父亲的女儿”，对吧？是的，绝对是个乖乖女。所以这种观念是：阿蒙不仅生下了她，还选定她为国王。因此，你在哈特谢普斯为自己建造的伟大神庙里会看到所有这些浮雕——
built for her on on the western side her great mortuary temple, that show her being born and show her being presented to the gods. And what's interesting is that when she's being presented to the gods as a kind of little baby, she's clearly male. She has a kind of male genitalia. And is that because that's the formula and they don't want to break from the formula? I mean, she's not trying to claim that she's a boy, obviously.
建在西岸的伟大的祭庙，展示她出生以及被引见给众神的情景。有趣的是，当她作为一个小婴儿被引见给众神时，她显然是个男性。她有一种男性的生殖器。这是因为那是既定的公式，他们不想打破这个公式吗？我的意思是，显然她并不是在试图宣称自己是个男孩。
No, she's not trying to claim that she's a boy obviously no she's not um so you know people people had all kinds of fun with this so freudians were fascinated by this yeah you know you know daddy issues all this kind of stuff and i guess you might you know we might be tempted now when gender fluidity is such a say she was non-binary to say you know was she was she non-binary uh i i think that would be a wholly anachronistic way of reading it. What she's doing is making play with the fact that to a degree, to be a king is to play a symbolic role. Yeah. But clearly this is imposing tensions. It does impose strains because it's obvious that she's not a man and she's not pretending to be a man. And so that's why sometimes she's portrayed as a woman sometimes
不，她显然不是在试图宣称自己是个男孩，不，她不是。所以，你知道的，人们对此进行了各种各样的解读：弗洛伊德主义者对此着迷——是的，你知道的，恋父情结之类的一大堆东西。我想你可能会——在性别流动性如此普遍的今天，我们可能很想说她是非二元性别者，去说“你知道的，她是非二元性别者吗？”——我认为用这种完全不合时宜的方式来解读它是极其荒谬的。她所做的是利用这样一个事实：在某种程度上，成为一个国王就是在扮演一个象征性的角色。是的。但这显然带来了紧张感。这确实造成了压力，因为很明显她不是个男人，她也没有假装自己是个男人。所以这就是为什么有时她被描绘成女性，有时
she's portrayed as a man what she does very interestingly is to give some of her predecessors female epithets so her father you know who we've described as an absolute lad he is described in in inscriptions put up by hapshitzut as the perfect goddess so that idea that you know if a woman can be play a man's role yeah kings have are also can play the the role of a goddess i mean you can completely understand why that that works for her because it to imply this sort of shifting from one to the other legitimizes her unprecedented place i mean it's not completely unprecedented but you know what i mean yeah and i think also it it kind of draws attention to the way in which she is she is um casting herself as a god and the idea that male and female roles in the dimension of the heaven are less secure than they are on earth is also a part of it so she's kind of
她被描绘成男性。她非常有趣的一点是，她赋予了她的一些前任女性称号。所以她的父亲——我们把他形容为一个绝对的花花公子——在哈特谢普斯树立的碑文中被描述为“完美的女神”。所以这种观念是：如果一个女人可以扮演男人的角色——是的——国王们其实也可以扮演女神的角色。我的意思是，你完全可以理解为什么这对她行得通，因为暗示这种从一种身份到另一种身份的转变，使她史无前例的地位合法化了——我的意思是，这并非完全史无前例，但你知道我的意思——是的。而且我认为这也吸引了人们的注意力，注意到她正在将自己塑造为一个神，而男女角色在天堂维度上不如在人间那么稳固，这也是其中一部分，所以她某种程度上
laying claim to that but it's clear that that there's a problem for people don't quite know what to call her right so it's in this period that her advisors start to come up with this circumlocution. So they start to call her after where she lives, i.e. The great house. The palace, the great house, which is transliterated as pharaoh, is what a pharaoh is. So before that, people weren't using the word pharaoh to refer to the kings. They used it to refer to the building. I'm not absolutely sure about that.
在宣称这一点。但很明显，这对人们来说是个问题，人们甚至不知道该怎么称呼她，对吧？所以正是在这段时期，她的谋士们开始想出这种委婉的说法。于是他们开始根据她居住的地方来称呼她，即“大屋”。宫殿，“大屋”，被音译为“法老”（Pharaoh），这就是法老这个词的由来。在此之前，人们并不用“法老”这个词来指代国王。他们用它来指代建筑物。我对这一点不是绝对确定。
And if there are any expert Egyptologists listening, perhaps they could let us know. But my understanding is that it's definitely from Hatchett's time that that phrase starts to come in. So it's equivalent of, you know, the White House or the palace. We don't call Joe Biden the White House. But I suppose it's plausible that in the long... I mean, we do use it as a...
如果有任何专业的埃及学家在听节目，也许他们可以告诉我们。但我的理解是，这个词确实是从哈特谢普斯的时代开始出现的。所以它相当于，你知道的，白宫或宫殿。我们不会把乔·拜登叫做“白宫”。但我想这是合情合理的，从长远来看……我的意思是，我们确实把它当作一个……
Yeah, but you say the White House says. Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. The palace denies this. The Elysee's position is Downing Street. Downing Street are telling us that, yeah, people do say that. And no doubt to our successors, that will seem ludicrous and bizarre, just as calling somebody the Great House does to us. So it works. It clearly works. Hatshepsut rules for 20 years and her reign is is incredibly successful so she launches the traditional campaigns against Kush it's possible that she went in person there are inscriptions that record the hands of slaughtered Kushites being cut off they would cut off either hands or penises and make great piles and count them to find out how many had been slaughtered and and and these there's an inscription describing these being
是的，但你会说“白宫表示”。是的，绝对的。绝对的。“宫殿否认这一点。”“爱丽舍宫的立场是……”“唐宁街……”“唐宁街告诉我们……”是的，人们确实会这么说。毫无疑问，对我们的后代来说，这听起来会荒谬而怪异，就像把某人称为“大屋”对我们来说一样。所以它行之有效。这显然行得通。哈特谢普斯统治了20年，她的统治取得了极其巨大的成功。因此她发起了针对库施的传统战役。她有可能亲自去过那里。有碑文记录了被屠杀的库施人的手被砍下来的情景。他们会砍下双手或生殖器，堆成大堆，然后数一数以查明到底被屠杀了多少人。并且有碑文描述了这些东西被
presented to her so it may be that she that she did take part in an actual campaign one of those images is definitely better than the other and one of those images is not one i care to think about too much no well and i and you know again the idea of severed penises being presented to a female king. Yeah. It's no wonder the Freudians have enjoyed it. And the other thing, of course, that Freudians would enjoy is her architectural extravaganzas. So in Karnak, she's a great sponsor of buildings there. And she has huge twin obelisks, which at the time were the largest ever erected, put at the entrance to the temple.
呈献给她，所以她有可能确实参与了一场真正的战役。这两个形象中，绝对有一个比另一个更好，而其中一个形象是我不太愿意多想的。不，好吧，而且——你知道的，再次提到把被砍下的生殖器呈献给一位女国王这回事。难怪弗洛伊德主义者会对此津津乐道。当然，弗洛伊德主义者会喜欢的另一件事是她铺张的建筑狂欢。所以在卡纳克，她是当地建筑的大力赞助商。她拥有巨大的双 obelisks（方尖碑），在当时是树立起来的最大的方尖碑，被放置在神庙的入口处。
And it's kind of sheathed in gold. Two obelisks of electrum, their pinnacles touching the heavens. That's what she says in the inscription. And again, a Freudian would kind of perhaps enjoy that. But her most famous building is the building that I already alluded to, her mortuary temple, which gets built on the west bank of the Nile. And it's stunningly beautiful.
而且它上面镀满了黄金。两座由琥珀金制成的方尖碑，它们的尖顶触及天堂。她在碑文中是这样说的。同样地，弗洛伊德主义者也许会对此津津乐道。但她最著名的建筑是我刚才已经提到的那座建在尼罗河西岸的祭庙。它美得令人惊叹。
Have you been to Egypt? I've never been, Tom. Never been to Egypt. Have you been? You clearly have. I have. Yes, I've been several times. And her mortuary temple,
你去过埃及吗？我从来没去过，汤姆。从来没去过埃及。你去过吗？你显然去过。我去过。是的，我去过好几次。她的祭庙，
which isn't just her mortuary temple. So it's also a mortuary temple for her father. So again, you know, daddy is there, but it's also full of different temples and shrines to the various gods, including Amun, all kinds of people like that. It was called by Hatshepsut, Jessa Jesseru, which is the Holy of Holies.
不仅仅是她的祭庙。它同时也是她父亲的祭庙。所以再次证明，父亲也在那里，但它也充满了献给各个神灵的不同神庙和神龛，包括阿蒙以及各种各样的神祇。它被哈特谢普斯命名为杰塞·杰瑟鲁（Djeser Djeseru），意为“圣中之圣”。
And it is, if you imagine a Greek temple designed by Le Corbusier, the great modernist architect, there is something modernist about it. There is something Greek about it.. There is something Greek about it. And there is something Egyptian about it. And it's a very unique, distinctive building. I mean, it's definitely one of the great buildings of ancient Egypt.
而且，如果你想象一下由伟大的现代主义建筑师勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）设计的希腊神庙，它确实带有一些现代主义色彩。它带有某种希腊风格。它带有某种希腊风格。它也带有某种埃及风格。这是一座非常独特、鲜明的建筑。我的意思是，它绝对是古埃及伟大的建筑之一。
It's maybe one of the great buildings in the entire world. It's absolutely stunning. And it's kind of arranged as a series of terraces with the cliff as the kind of backdrop. And this cliff on the other side is where the Valley of the Kings is. So her tomb is on that side. The Mortuary Temple is on the side that is facing the Nile. And actually, do you know what the path is that joins them? I don't, Tom.
它或许是整个世界上最伟大的建筑之一。它绝对令人惊叹。它以一系列阶梯的形式排列，以悬崖作为背景。悬崖的另一边就是帝王谷。所以她的陵墓在那一边。而祭庙则位于面朝尼罗河的那一边。事实上，你知道连接它们的路径是什么吗？我不知道，汤姆。
It's called Agatha Christie's Path. Oh. Because it's a path that features in- Death on the Mount. The novel. No, it features in Death Comes as the End, which is a path that that features in death on the mouth the novel no it's um it features in death comes as the end which is the novel that she set in ancient egypt which isn't very good actually i don't think but anyway let's no but it's nice to know that you know
它被称为“阿加莎·克里斯蒂之路”。哦。因为它是一条出现在——《尼罗河上的惨案》小说中的路。不，它出现在《死者来得无声》（Death Comes as the End）里——这是一条出现在《尼罗河上的惨案》小说中的路。不，它出现在《死者来得无声》里，这是她以古埃及为背景的小说，其实我觉得写得不是很好，但不管怎样，我们还是……不，但很高兴知道……
there's an anchor the christie link definitely and so from the point of view of um making sense of hatchet soot's life the great thing about this this huge temple is that there are a beautiful exquisitely carved and painted scenes from her life. So it's here that we get the portrait of her divine birth, her election by the gods. There are scenes showing her obelisks being transported. And most famously, there is the illustration of an expedition that she sent out to a land called Punt. Ah, right. And Punt seems to, it's a kind of simultaneously
这里确实有一个与阿加莎·克里斯蒂的联系。所以，从理解哈特谢普斯一生的角度来看，这座宏伟神庙最棒的地方在于，里面有精美绝伦、雕刻和彩绘描绘她生平的场景。正是在这里，我们看到了她神圣出生、被神灵选中的肖像。有展示她的方尖碑被运输的场景。而最著名的，是她派遣远征队前往一个名为朋特（Punt）的土地的插图。啊，没错。朋特似乎……它既是一个……
a mythical land and a land that seems actually to have existed so perhaps the horn of africa i think is is the most popular location for it and it shows uh all kinds of um wonderful treasures being brought back so wild animals maybe uh rhinoceros maybe giraffes and so it shows all kinds of of wonderful things being brought back by this expedition that hatchet so it's sent so exotic plants and these plants are then planted on her mortuary temple um ebony ivory perfumes so the perfumes when amun impregnates hatchatshepsut's mother are described as having come from Punt. Right. That's how beautiful they are.
神话般的土地，又是一个似乎确实存在的土地。所以非洲之角我认为是它最可能的位置。它展示了各种各样的美妙宝藏被带回来：野生动物，比如犀牛、长颈鹿。所以它展示了哈特谢普斯派遣的这支远征队带回来的各种各样美妙的东西：异国植物，这些植物后来被种在她的祭庙里；乌木、象牙、香水——因此，当阿蒙使哈特谢普斯的母亲怀孕时，这些香水被描述为来自朋特。没错。它们就是这么美妙。
And also there are wonderful scenes of Punt. So there's a house on stilts with a kind of turtle floating underneath it, swimming underneath it. And most famously of all, they show the queen of Punt, who it is fair to describe as a woman of size. A woman of size. She's very, very large. Right. describe as a woman of size. She's very, very large. And this is all kind of showing Hapshetsut as able to construct stunning architecture and to commission vast kind of trading expeditions. So this is the model of what it is to be a great queen. But in terms of the real Hapshetsut,
此外，还有关于朋特的精彩场景。这里有一座高脚屋，下面有一只乌龟在漂浮、在游动。最著名的，是他们展示了朋特的王后，公平地说，她可以被描述为一个“大码女性”。一个大码女性。她非常非常大。没错。可以被描述为一个大码女性。她非常非常大。这一切都在某种程度上展示了哈特谢普斯能够建造令人惊叹的建筑，并委托开展庞大的贸易远征。所以这就是成为一个伟大女王的典范。但就真正的哈特谢普斯而言，
what's going on? What are the dynamics of the court? There is one intriguing clue that is to be found very, very discreetly placed within this mortuary temple, which is the portrayal of someone who is not royal, a man called Senenmut. And Senenmut is the great right-hand man. so he's the architect and a tutor and and what else tutor tutor to the hatchet so it's daughter um overseer of the audience chamber steward of the queen's estates steward of amun overseer of all the king's works responsible for the for the for the mortuary temple responsible for the obelisks. And he has himself portrayed in the upper sanctuary, you know, which is kind of unheard of. Yeah.
究竟发生了什么？宫廷内部的权力动态是怎样的？有一个耐人寻味的线索，被非常非常低调地放置在这座祭庙内部，那就是对一个非皇室成员的描绘，一个名叫塞宁穆特（Senenmut）的男子。塞宁穆特是她伟大的得力助手。所以他是建筑师、导师，还有什么？哈特谢普斯女儿的导师……接见厅总管、女王庄园总管、阿蒙总管、国王所有工程的总监、负责祭庙、负责方尖碑。他让自己被描绘在上层圣殿里，你知道的，这简直是闻所未闻的。是的。
This is the most sacred part of the temple. So very, very strange. And we have details of his life also from two enormous tombs that he built for himself, which he portrays itself very much as a kind of rags to riches story. And there are actually, you know, there are 26 surviving statues of him is he is he possibly are they more than friends tom well so this is this is the great question yeah so there was a there was um an ostracon a kind of a shard of pottery found in the great workman's village where the workmen who who labored on the mortuary temples and in the valley of the kings lived and it shows what seems to be a man having sex with a woman wearing a pharaoh's headdress. And it's often been suggested that this might be a kind of scurrilous portrayal of Senenmut and Hapchetsut.
这是神庙最神圣的部分。所以非常非常奇怪。我们还可以从他为自己建造的两座宏大陵墓中了解他生平的细节，在陵墓中他把自己描绘成一个标准的“白手起家”的故事。事实上，现存有关于他的雕像多达26尊。他会不会……他们俩不仅仅是朋友吗，汤姆？嗯，所以这就是最大的问题。是的。因此，在大工匠村——那些在祭庙和帝王谷辛勤劳动的工匠们居住的地方——曾发现过一块陶片（ostracon），上面似乎画着一个男人正在和一个戴着法老头饰的女人做爱。人们经常有人建议说，这可能是对塞宁穆特和哈特谢普斯的一种恶意丑化。
I mean, we don't know for sure. Might be, might not be. But obviously, there are all kinds of questions around that. So one of the things that's intriguing about Senenmut is that he doesn't seem to have had a wife, which is incredibly unusual. I mean, unheard of for a prominent Egyptian not to have had a wife. It has been suggested that perhaps this is a bit like the Earl of Leicester or the Earl of Essex with Elizabeth I, kind of playing down the fact that they're married.
我的意思是，我们并不能确定。可能是，也可能不是。但很显然，围绕这一点有各种各样的问题。因此，关于塞宁穆特，引人入胜的一点是，他似乎从未结过婚，这极其不同寻常。我的意思是，对于一个显赫的埃及人来说，没有结婚是闻所未闻的。有人提出，这可能有点像伊丽莎白一世时期的莱斯特伯爵或埃塞克斯伯爵，他们试图淡化自己已婚的事实。
You know, there would be nothing to stop Hatshepsut having a relationship with him if she'd wanted. But would that not have meant that she was no longer the king? Yes, exactly. Well, no, it wouldn't, but it might've compromised her role. As with Elizabeth I. Essentially, she has, yes,
你知道的，如果哈特谢普斯愿意，没有什么能阻止她与他保持某种关系。但这不就意味着她不再是国王了吗？是的，完全正确。好吧，不，这不会，但它可能会损害她的角色。就像伊丽莎白一世一样。本质上，她有，是的，
she cannot afford to marry. So there is a kind of, you know, intriguing Elizabeth I parallel there. And the other thing that complicates it is that Selenmuk doesn't seem to have been buried in either of his tombs so we again we don't know what happened there was he assassinated was he disgraced and this is the kind of the frustration of egyptian history is that you get the scent of all these kind of extraordinary narratives but not enough evidence and some listeners might say oh gosh typical blokes they can't read about a powerful
她负担不起结婚的代价。所以这里存在着一种引人入胜的伊丽莎白一世式的平行关系。让情况变得更复杂的是，塞宁穆特似乎并没有被埋葬在他的任何一座陵墓里，所以我们再次不知道发生了什么：他是被暗杀了？还是失宠了？这就是埃及历史令人沮丧的地方，你捕捉到了所有这些非凡故事的气息，却缺乏足够的证据。有些听众可能会说：“天哪，典型的男人，他们一看到一个有权势的女人有一个令人印象深刻的男性得力助手，就忍不住想象他们睡在一起。”所以也有可能，其实根本没有这回事——这绝对是有可能的，因为我认为，很显然，他们的伙伴关系建立在一种对“国王能做什么”的共同认知之上。我的意思是，哈特谢普斯陵庙非凡的建筑风格在她修复或开发的其它神庙中也能看到。所以她还赞助了卡纳克的许多建筑。这些建筑非常非常具有创新性、非常sophisticated（精妙）、新颖。灵感肯定来自于哈特谢普斯，
woman having a you know an impressive male right hand without imagining that they're in bed together so it's also possible that there's there's nothing to there's no absolutely possible because i think i think it's clear that the partnership was one that was founded on a kind of shared sense of what was possible for a king to do. I mean, the extraordinary architecture of Hatshepsut's funerary temple is evident in other temples that she either restored or developed. So she also sponsors lots of buildings in Karnak. And these are very, very innovative, very kind of sophisticated novel. It must have come from Hatshepsut, the inspiration for this, but she needed someone to
但她需要有人来为她实现。显然是塞宁穆特在做这件事。所以这里显然有一种……思想上的碰撞。他是一个非常非常能干的男人。她是一个非常非常能干的女人。他们共同创造了这些非凡的纪念碑，但我们不知道他的结局如何。而且，我们也不知道的另一件事是，在她死后，人们是如何纪念她的具体情况。她似乎是自然死亡，可能在30多岁快40岁时，对埃及人来说这已经是享年高寿了。年轻的图特摩斯三世继位。所以他一直在耐心等待。他等得非常非常耐心。而当哈特谢普斯去世时，迦南那些曾臣服于埃及的人立即发动了叛乱，我认为这是一个极其说明问题的致敬，是对哈特谢普斯威望的致敬：人们觉得，这个女人去世了，紧接着由她的男性继承人继位，迦南人民认为这是一个揭竿而起的好机会。
do it for her. And clearly it's Senenmut who's doing that. So there is clearly a kind of mixing of, you know, a meeting of minds there. He's a very, very able man. She's a very, very able woman. And together they create these remarkable monuments, but we don't know what happens to him. And also the other thing that we don't know is the exact circumstances of how she is remembered when she dies. She seems to have died naturally, maybe late 30s, 40s, which was, you know, a ripe old age for Egyptians. And she is succeeded by the young Thutmose III. So he's been waiting patiently all this time. He's been waiting very, very patiently. And what happens when Hatshepsut dies is that the people in Canaan who've been subject to Egypt immediately rise in revolt, which I think is an incredibly telling tribute to Hatshepsut's renown, that it's felt, you know, that this woman dies and immediately, you know, succeeded by her male heir. And it's assumed by the people in Canaan that this is an opportunity for them to rise up in revolt.
所以这是对她威望的一种致敬。然而，这对他们来说是一个非常糟糕的错误，因为图特摩斯三世将证明自己也许是整个埃及历史上最能干的军事统帅。他气势汹汹地杀过去。我的意思是，他把他们彻底夷为平地。他在米吉多（Megiddo，即后来的“世界末日”Armageddon）赢得了一场伟大的战役。他统治了33年，这是一个绝对辉煌的统治，取得了巨大的成功。而在某个时候，有人试图毁损哈特谢普斯的纪念碑。这很有趣。所以我们之前做过一期关于阿肯那顿的节目，他也遭遇了这种情况——这是一种非常非常彻底的“记忆灭绝”（damnatio memoriae）企图，旨在抹去他的记忆，消灭他的名字。一个非常流行的理论认为，这是图特摩斯三世对他姑妈怨恨的一种表达。但其中的复杂之处在于，首先，
So it's a tribute to her renown. Very bad mistake on their part, however, because Thutmose III will prove himself to be perhaps the most able military leader in the whole of Egyptian history. He goes bombing off. I mean, he absolutely flattens them. He wins a great battle at Megiddo, Armageddon, as it will in due course become. he rules for 33 years absolutely glorious reign tremendous success and at some point an attempt is made to deface Hatshepsut's monuments that's interesting so we earlier we did one on Akhenaten and this happened to him a very very kind of total damnatio memoriae attempt to erase his his memory, wipe out his name. And it's been a very popular theory that this is an expression of Thutmose III's resentment against his aunt. But the complication with that is that, well, firstly, I mean, it would have been very easy
他要发动政变是非常容易的。他是个年轻力壮的男子，掌控着军队。他完全可以轻易推翻他的姑妈。但他似乎并没有这样做。我的意思是，他没有那样做。他让她自然死亡。第二点是，这种试图将哈特谢普斯从记录中抹去的企图，似乎发生在她死后几十年。因此，我认为最合理的理论是，被针对的目标其实并不是哈特谢普斯本人，而是她如何将自己塑造成国王的那段记忆。这似乎是一种企图，旨在确立这样一个事实：女性不能作为国王统治。这是因为他自己的继承人受到了女人的威胁吗？我想大概是的。我的意思是，基本上，这试图确保女性能够扮演摄政王的角色，
for him to stage a coup. He's a young man. He's in charge of the army. He could easily have toppled his aunt. He doesn't seem to have done it. I mean, he didn't do that. He lets her die of natural causes. And the second thing is that this seems to have happened this this attempt to erase uh hatchet soot from the from the record seems to have happened several decades after her death and so the likely theory i think is that what is being targeted isn't hatchet soot herself but the memory of the way in which she'd made herself king. And so it seems to have been a kind of an attempt to establish the fact that women could not rule as kings. Is that because his own heir is threatened by a woman? I think probably, yes. I mean, it's basically, it's trying to put, it's trying to ensure that women play the role of
但不能扮演国王。当然，在第十八王朝随后的历史中，确实出现了一些非常强大的女性人物，其中最著名的就是娜菲尔提蒂（Nefertiti），并且曾有一种论点认为她确实作为国王统治过，但这不太可能。所以，本质上，这似乎就是主要原因，而且它似乎相当粗略，否则我们就不会知道哈特谢普斯了。我们确实有她的碑文，某种记忆也被保留了下来——尽管她的名字没有被保存在国王列表中，但她并没有像阿肯那顿那样从历史记忆中被完全抹去，对吧？所以历史学家不需要费力去重新发掘她……她没有被记住曾是一个女人，所以她某种程度上是被当作一个男人来纪念的。
regents, but not of of kings and you do have obviously very powerful female figures that follow through the 18th dynasty of whom nefertiti is the most famous and there has been a thesis that she did actually rule as as king but unlikely um so essentially that seems to have been the the thing and it and it seems to be pretty cursory because otherwise we wouldn't know about hatchet so we do have her inscriptions and a kind of memory was preserved so her name wasn't preserved in the king lists but she wasn't completely erased from historical memory in the way that akhenaten was right so historians didn't have to kind of recover her they kind of did she it wasn't remembered that she'd been a woman so she's kind of commemorated as a man.
哦，对了。天哪。所以发现她是个女人，在某种程度上……这虽然不如发现阿肯那顿和图坦卡蒙那么令人兴奋，但也相当令人兴奋。这就是为什么她被人们铭记，我认为。当然，我的意思是，她一定赢得了女权主义历史学家和性别史学家的喜爱，正如你所说的那样。研究古埃及性别议题的人一定对她情有独钟。是的。好吧，我的意思是，她是一个迷人的人物，有点像伊丽莎白一世，我猜。她的角色与性别之间的紧张关系显然令人着迷。而她在这方面取得的巨大成功，意味着她更是一个引人入胜的研究课题。当然，你知道，这方面的时尚潮流变化很快——是的——所以当她最初被发现时采用的基调，
Oh, right. Crikey. So the discovery that she was a woman was kind of, you know, it wasn't quite an excitement on the level of discovering Akhenaten and Tutankhamen, but it was pretty exciting. And that's why she's remembered, I think. Well, also, I mean, she must really endear herself to feminist historians and historians, as you were saying, of gender. People who write about gender in ancient Egypt must be all over her. Yeah. Well, I mean, she's a fascinating figure, rather in the way that Elizabeth I is, I guess. The tension between her role and her gender is obviously fascinating. And the fact that she was so successful with it means that she's all the more a kind of intriguing subject of study and of course you know fashions in this change so yeah so quickly the the tone that was adopted when she was first
因为历史主要由男性撰写，所以带有极度严重的性别歧视；然后是弗洛伊德主义的兴起；接着是70年代女权主义冲击的影响；而现在，我确信有各种各样性别流动视角的解读。这反映了一个事实：恰好有足够多的证据来产生这些热门见解，但又不足以推翻它们。这既是埃及历史的魅力所在，也是其令人沮丧之处。但我想你会说，如果你试图去……我的意思是，你可以看出她非常强大，因为她在这样一个前所未有的角色中坚持了这么久。而且她创造了令人惊叹的建筑。
discovered because the histories were mainly being written by men fabulously sexist then you have kind of freudianism then you have the effect of of feminism and kicking it in the 70s now i i'm sure there are all kinds of gender fluid takes. And it reflects, you know, the fact that there's just enough to kind of generate these hot takes. Yeah. But not enough to disprove them. And that's both the fascination and the frustration of Egyptian history. But I suppose what you would say is if you were trying to, I mean, you can tell she's formidable because she lasts so long in such an unprecedented role. And she creates a stunning architecture.
是的，令人惊叹的建筑。但除此之外，她的侄子图特摩斯三世的巨大成功也证明了这一点。我的意思是，你说过他几乎是所有埃及法老中最伟大的。你知道的，他在近东地区的权力是无可挑战的，对吧？是的。我的意思是，你可以争辩说他是在她的基础上……好吧，他确实是在为她奠定基础，不是吗？他绝对是的。是的，他绝对是。所以这是一个非常令人印象深刻的女人，汤姆。我想……你觉得我为自己的观点辩护成功了吗？我想你确实成功为自己的观点进行了辩护。
Yeah, an amazing architecture. But also then the very fact of her nephew Thutmose III's success. I mean, you said he's pretty much the greatest of all Egyptian pharaohs. You know, his power is unchallenged, isn't it, in the Near East generally? Yeah. I mean, you could argue he's building on her well he is building her foundations isn't he he absolutely is yeah he absolutely is so very impressive woman tom i think um do you think i justified my claim i think you have justified your claim actually
是的，你做到了。我想……我依然……我依然对你在前半段关于乱伦的言论感到震惊。我是在暗示你对科学的兴趣，而不是你的首要任务。我只是想把这一点绝对挑明。这整个播客期间我一直记在心里。哦，难怪你刚才一直这么安静。是的，我知道，这太前所未有了，真的前所未有。不，那太迷人了，汤姆，真的很有趣。我们应该做更多期——我们会做更多关于强大女性的节目，但我认为也应该多做一些关于埃及的内容。我很想在某个时候聊聊金字塔，金字塔、埃及的起源，所有这些内容，那会非常有趣。非常赞同，我非常赞同。所以我们有很多有趣的内容要推出，对吧？我们有“真正的唐顿庄园”，我想那是我们的下一期节目。我们有很多关于“真正的”内容的节目，因为我们有“真正的达芬奇密码”。我们将讨论卡特尔派的历史。我们将讨论罗纳德·里根的生平和总统任期。汤姆会进行模仿表演。我们将讨论哥伦布。我们有无数有趣的内容。
yeah you have i think um i'm still i'm still shocked that you made that remark about incest in the first half i was alluding i was alluding to your interest in science not your priorities i just want that put absolutely that's been on my mind the whole podcast oh no wonder you've been so quiet yeah i know it's unprecedented that really is unprecedented no that was fascinating tom it's really interesting and um we should do more we and we will do more powerful women but i think also more on egypt i mean love to do the pyramids at some point the pyramid beginnings of egypt all
所以，汤姆，非常感谢你带来这番堪称精彩绝伦的讲述。你过奖了。我们下次节目再见。再见。再见。谢谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest
that kind of stuff that would be great fun very much i'm very much up for that so we have lots of fun things coming up don't we we have the uh the real downton abbey i think is our next episode we have the real we have a lot of real things because we have the real da Vinci code. We're going to be talking about the story of the Cathars. We're going to be talking about the life and presidency of Ronald Reagan. Tom will be doing an impersonation. We are doing Columbus. We have tons of fun things.
is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告畅听、番外节目……本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
So Tom, thank you so much for what I can only describe as a tour de force. You're too kind. And we will see you all next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. you're too kind and we will see you all next time goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest
汤姆，非常感谢你带来这番堪称精彩绝伦的精彩讲述。你过奖了。我们下期节目再见。再见。再见。你过奖了，我们下期节目再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余部分》
Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是娱乐。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的良药。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听和独家福利……本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。